[Music]
so my name is Alex O'Keefe I am the
2018-19 crest fellow and art
librarianship so I work in the Hart's
library and I've been working on
ensemble at Yale for my project as the
crust fellow so the projects I'm
presenting today is ensemble at Yale
which is a long-standing project before
I got here a collaboration between the D
H lab and then the Haas Arts Library
representative Lindsay King in order to
preserve Yale drama history what we're
doing is we have digitized programs from
the 1920s through about 2016 that we are
asking people to transcribe so it's a
crowdsource transcription project which
is really exciting because it means we
get to work with people a lot and so we
basically have the actors and their
roles and we're trying to get people to
transcribe the names so that we have a
data set that we can later use to
maximize asking questions about the Yale
rep that we don't know right now I think
the most exciting part of this project
has been working to invigorate a
volunteer base so when I first came on
we had the project was all set up and
ready to go thanks to the D H lab and
all of the efforts that came before me
but my big initiative has been bringing
in the people and getting them excited
about our project since crowdsourcing
requires the people a crowd as we say
the crowd and crowdsourcing we have been
trying really hard to create programming
and create opportunities for people to
come together over these exciting
materials and learn more about the
history with us as we also produce the
product of data set for later use so
once we have all the crowd source data
together we're working now on what we
want that to look like for the
population to access it essentially so
we would definitely are working on
ingesting it and to find it at Yale
which is the Yale side of things but we
also have hoping to do some more data
visualization options like using Jeffie
and social networking mapping in order
to show more of the relationships
between these people in their lives
again from the 20s through about 20
sixteen so the conversations were having
today have been really exciting to be a
part of especially listening to all of
the speakers before coming to the poster
session I'm hoping that I'll trade off
with my colleagues seem to walk around
and talk to more people but it's just
the energy in the room as well as the
diversity of digital mayonese projects
is just so exciting to see and to see
how everyone is maximizing the different
areas to create these really interesting
projects flowering at the Dage lab has
been excellent everyone has been really
helpful we have lots of times with to
troubleshoot together and everyone's
very open and helpful in every angle
that we've had and then across was so
we've been very excited to represent at
Beyond Boundaries today
my name is Maya Levin I'm a junior I'm
studying the history of science in
medicine and ecology in evolutionary
biology but I'm here in my capacity as a
history of science and medicine major
and I'm a third-year undergrad so I'm
working with dr. Carolyn Roberts in the
history of science and medicine
department to look at manifests from
slave trade ships across during the
transatlantic slave trade looking at the
Latin pharmaceutical abbreviations of
medication names expanding them into
usable Latin terms and then finding an
English vernacular name for those
medications and eventually turning them
into a database that people can use to
answer historical questions across time
about medications both explicitly in the
slave trade and more broadly also hoping
to sort of trace those medications back
to diseases that people were expecting
to encounter during the slave trade as
we can look at sort of likelihood cost
and amount of medications that were
people were bringing onto slave trades
chips so lessons learned I think that
transcription is something that is
really an important skill and that we
shouldn't lose it as digitization
becomes something really important
because though it may seem that this is
sort of legible and doable handwriting
I'm not sure how much the camera can
pick it up and it's actually not able to
be read by a digital tool at this point
so it still needs to be done by a human
and I think that's a skill that is
really important to keep up as we think
about the way that digitization and
humanities will stay united and then
another lesson learned really is that
looking at historical medication it's
important to sort of take a lens of
judgment away I think it's very easy to
look at these medications and think
obviously they shouldn't be giving
anyone mercury I don't know what you're
doing but actually looking at the ways
that people were developing medication
over time and thinking critically about
that but also giving them a little bit
of benefit I think can give you insight
into people in this time period and the
way that they were thinking about
medicine that's much more valuable so
next step is really expansion of the
data set for now we have about 75
entries in this for
but we've only worked with two entries
from actual manifests so expanding those
hoping to find more manifests in the
future and then hoping to find other
students that can help expand this data
set so that it can be turned into an
interactive database that people can
really use
so one thing I think that appears
clearly in the beyond boundaries today
is that the feel is in general of
digital humanities is evolving we are
not presenting project only we are
discussing together about what makes
digital humanities meaningful and that
comes to a good time because I think the
debates needs to be reshaped and
modified because a lot of things we're
kind of endless and circling questions
they don't know maybe a bit behind us
considering how inspiring and how
interesting the question and things that
were to discuss today we're so that's a
great great I think there are great oaks
for this field
graduate some hard
17th century French literature in the
culture and the project was kind of
we period within that
backcourts and
basically a manuscript of the 17th
century comedy and learnt texting Pony
using XML ETI standards and then
realized that there were a number of
different interfaces so each group
decided to envision the scene that they
were responsible for and as
and we were also working with a team at
the University in Seattle so we were
escaping with them throughout and
collaborating
translating the book from the object
moves to a digital version perfect it's
also a way to reread the the work the
literary work in a new way it's not just
putting the text online its
it's rethinking about our relationship
to the to a book our relationship to
literary works and it's a lot of new
questions and new topics for us our
researcher
[Music]
that kind of kept the workflow
as you can see they all look pretty
different and I think that kind of one
thing that we learned is that your
interviews really choose it as a
function of what you want to portray in
the text let's relax
please talk to myself Madison completed
this one and these ones are I would say
much more about the performativity of
the text much less about maybe the text
itself whereas this one which is Doyle's
showcases variations across different
editions of the text so it's a much
academic
yeah so we all chose different scenes
and as Molly said we kind of had to read
our seams as he
saying content-wise
or structurally to share
and you had to debate with your may with
your partners at the University of
Washington in Seattle to elaborate those
interfaces so this one is the animated
it's designed to function like a
whatsapp message so we made the choice
to not modernize the text at all but
rather just to kind of show how this
kind of conversation is still relevant
today this specific text is for this
scene is kind of about gender roles in
the 17th century as they were conveyed
in this play
so we've color-coded the text to show or
the text messages to show the different
genders and so we kind of envisioned
this more as like an animated interface
that could be used as a pedagogical tool
to show how one can read kind of at any
level of French or expertise of the 17th
century how one can read this text today
so my scene deals with a bourgeois woman
he was trying to purchase pretending to
be from a higher class than she actually
is and she says all sorts of lies about
the way that she has carriage and as the
scene progresses however the other
characters see from her lies and her the
image that she's trying to project and I
was reading a lot about selfies and sort
of social appearances on social media
and thinking through these questions but
were very present in this scene we think
of them as contemporary so I wanted to
show that it's sort of one of the
subtext of the scene and I wanted to
make that
a visual so I chose the mirror what
would be an iPhone today and showed her
self image cracking as all of her lies
are revealed to be lies
and was really thinking about how to
make the subject matter more relatable
to a contemporary reader
my name is Sol Sadiq and I am a second
year MFA graduate in the sculpture
Department the project title is named
turaga
and it is using neural style transfer to
generate images in the likeness of an
artist that recently passed away I've
learned so a lot like I personally don't
have a background in coding or
programming and so I mean I've taken
like online code Academy classes but the
D H lab has helped me so much in order
to kind of like set up the system and
teach me how to use it and being able to
use it and just yeah just constantly
learning while working with like the
programs yeah it's like constantly new
for me so would like the neural spell
transfer there's like multiple ways that
you can use it you can
use like color scale in order to shift
colors around as well as like content
and style weight so I found that to be
really generative in the ways that
taking certain like content images and
applying the style and to play around
with that to kind of start to like
understand the program a bit more and to
understand what it's doing
yeah so that was yeah that was like ways
that like learning through programs so
this is a image like an of the artists
painting so this is one of the paintings
and this is another painting so what I
had done is use these two paintings as
the style weights and from there I had
taken images from his iPhone that are
used as like like inspirational
references and photoshopped them
together in order to generate a new
image that would be like in the likeness
of a potential painting he could have
created
yeah
[Music]
so this is a painting of is but also
combining multiple paintings to kind of
create different colorways as well just
like having access to the technology and
also its ability to process the
information and a lot quicker so being
able to have like the images available
in like a shorter time and just having
like the support as well yeah to like
learn the program and yeah it's been
it's been a really great experience my
name is Adam Erickson I'm an
undergraduate student senior I'm
majoring in applied mathematics and
physics I'm working with a professor at
the school management and we are working
on building an interface to view time
series data and this time series happens
to be topic modeling on The Wall Street
Journal so it's a corpus of natural
language and it doesn't fit really well
as a visualization on paper so to really
explore all the features thought it'd be
good to build a web interface so we used
react Jas which is a JavaScript library
it's Facebook open source project for
building user interfaces we also uses
another open source library from the
Department of Energy for viewing time
series data which wraps react around d3
basically because both react and d3 want
to make updates to the Dom document
object model of HTML and this package
helps them play nicely with each other
we do this so that then we can like load
in the CSV files these files are the
time series data so you know value at
certain points in time such that we
could you know someday feed in new data
and we wouldn't have to update any of
the
so we have a menu here where you can
choose which time series you want to
appear on the plot and this we hope
could be of arbitrary length sometime in
the future and you see here I'll unclick
them some of them but you see it starts
with a totally blank canvas which we'll
get to in a second here and then as you
start to select them it begins to draw
the plots and as you mouse over it tells
you the value of the time series at
certain points in time so because these
are newspaper articles each topic is a
topic that might appear in the newspaper
and then the value for a certain month
is the article which most represents
that topic during that month it's like
the top headline more or less and you
can add a bunch and overlay them for
example here we have the topic of police
crime mobile devices in Internet and you
can mouse over them and see how they
change throughout time and compare them
and then if you select them on one axes
you can get some more absolute
comparisons of their relative
proportions so you might see a spike
right here in Internet and then think
like Oh what kind of was happening
around that time and because all the
proportions over all the topics sum to
one you might see like oh when this one
went up interest and the other one went
down things like that yeah I'll say
yeah so this is still prototype but one
quick thing you can do to check out an
example might be ok I would choose the
topic of the Internet so then you can
see that time series and see like oh in
1985 there was a lot less discussion of
the Internet in the news paper then
there was right here around 2000 the
dot-com bubble you can see there's some
articles about double-click hi I was
alive at that time but not super
conscious so I don't remember this but I
know around 2000 Salah was happening
within
the one which really has a huge spike is
if you choose natural disasters which
you can see even Dwarfs the spike in the
internet and this is right after
Hurricane Katrina is when the topic
proportion really spikes in the
newspaper so yeah those are the sorts of
things trends you might like to look for
and use this interface for and really
what's nice is you could choose
arbitrary number of topics and not have
to worry about how it updates the screen
definitely I learned a lot about
front-end development using javascript
and react and things like that
asynchronous programming especially is
difficult so if you're writing a
something more low-level or back-end or
like a project you might do in one of
the cs classes here you can kind of
anticipate how it's going to be used but
when you make a user interface you don't
know in what order the user might do
things so you have to build it such that
like you know clicks drag scrolls
whatever could happen in any order so
you're so you're prepared for anything
the user might do to use it well or even
if they were trying to break it and
testing or something so that was really
difficult and that is what react helps
do for building user interfaces really
makes it a lot easier to handle state
and to write the program the interface
such that like oh it doesn't matter what
order the user does things in because I
want to it's declarative so I want to
declare how the front-end will be used
yeah a lot about that and I was really
interested
[Music]